Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
insertion point relocation. So Burp Scanner during the crawl is trying to find paths through an
application to each request that it will then want to audit so that when we go back to that
request it's valid, everything's up to date, it's all in session, sort of like automatic session
handling. This means that when we are resending our base requests during the audit they might
change slightly. Things like cookies or session tokens or cash busters might update with each
time we send the request and if anything we kind of expect them to. That's why we're doing our
automatic session handling to make sure they're valid and fresh and up to date each time. The
problem with this is that as that request changes the part of the request that we're actually trying
to put our payload in might need to move slightly. So for example this foo parameter here is after
this token parameter here with the value x. If this value changed length each time this base request was
resubmitted then the foo parameter would kind of move slightly to the right each time its offsets would
change. If we just use hard-coded offsets for our insertion points then we could end up placing our
payload in completely the wrong place resulting in a malformed request. Instead, Burp Scanner understands
the features of the insertion point it's using and can dynamically relocate each time. So to
demonstrate this I've put together this really simple web application. It's got two pages. A first page
that has a single form on it. This form each time we visit it has this hidden token parameter with the value
of x and with each visit this parameter value gets slightly longer. When the form is submitted that
parameter is validated and if it's not of the right length we reject the form submission. So if I send this
to repeater because I've already done a scan of this that length isn't valid anymore. So I previously run a
scan of this application and if we head over to the logger we can see that each request has a payload
in the place in the correct spot for the value of the parameter we're attacking. So with each of these
even though the parameter is moving we're putting our payload in the correct place. Burp Scanner can
also handle insertion point index changing. So for example if those two parameters swapped order and it
can also handle insertion point name changes. I wanted to keep the demo nice and simple so I didn't cover
either of those. So you'll just have to take my word for it or you could try it out yourself.
So you can see that.